ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
また現代社会を表す四字熟語をつくってみた
旅行している自分の写真を撮るため旅行する人
側壁耐震再生数のために洗剤を飲んだりコカコーラのお風呂に入ったりすること
西湘肉
大東つの写真をインスタンにアップし自分がなぜそうしたのかわからないから急に泣き
だすこと
30恐怖青外れない人たちがコメント欄で喧嘩すること
真空喧嘩ティンダーで自分よりずっと見た目のいい人とマッチングした時の気持ち
不安視子いいねぇやリツイートの数を見て道徳を作る人
生地
東鉄神スタンプを使いすぎて複雑な感情を言葉では伝えられない人
画像依存動画が嫌いだというのに毎回毎回コメントを残してくれる人
役立つ迷惑起こっていない人の代わりに起こること
平等主義女が twitter で自分のことをネコということ
もしくは男が明言
と一緒にセルフィーをアップすること青年期機ダイレクトメッセージの冒頭文書
うん
一言二人の美女が facebook で褒め言葉を交わし密かに喧嘩すること
電子尊師2人の乱暴な男がフェイスブックで脅迫を交わし露骨に喧嘩すること
現代原子 bds が好きだと思いこんでいる人
洗脳軍隊読んでもいない本の写真を撮りそれをネットにアップすること
表紙
判断自分の作品に自信がないから視聴者たちにギフトカードを配ったり動画を最後まで
見てねっと言ったりするクリエイター
近代サッカー
ni